this looking at this made me want to ask  you if there's one place in all of your  books that you would like to live in  which one would that be one place that I  would like to live in a city or a castle  allora  well I mean there are aspects about a  number of them that that attract me you  know I do like cold weather so I  actually probably would like Winterfell  you know there the cold winds never gets  too hot there that's good I would like  that Casterly Rock has a advantage of  having a lots of gold so you could be  very very rich living there there the  IRA has magnificent views you know down  in Dorne you you get great spicy food  and great spicy women so that's good you  know but ultimately I think I'd like to  stay in Santa Fe New Mexico we have like  modern medicine and and the NFL on  Sunday they'll know after the after the  way the Jets played to get me give that  up